president biden battered in recent weeks
by a bunch of bad economic news
struggling to solve the ongoing supply
chain jam that is set to ruin your
christmas thanks to a huge backlog of
ships still bogging down those ports out
west
and thanks to inflation this year's
thanksgiving feast shaping up to be the
most expensive meal in the history
of the holiday but despite it all the
president says the economy is doing just
fine
trump likes to boast the single best
measure of the economy is the stock
market i never thought that
well if that's true
take a look at the stock market now it's
harder than it ever been not only that
more people working today than just
before the pandemic started household
wealth is up people are buying more
things manufacturing is up
we're on the move but we're on the right
track
on the right track but even katie
democrats apparently believe he's on the
wrong track yeah and the surveys that
you see the polls that are taking
showing his unpopularity it's democrats
who are deserting the ship democrats
independents you have a lot of democrat
economic experts who worked for people
like president obama saying this
inflation problem is going to get worse
and the body administration a wanting to
spend more money and b ignoring the
problem is not going to make it go away
the white house has been staying for
months that this is just transitory it
will be over in a couple of months and
now we're seeing the fed chair say
actually it's not going to be over until
the end of 2022. so a full year from now
plus some that's when they say it will
end don't have a lot of credibility on
that when you look at this as a whole
and who's really running the economy
it's bernie sanders who is in charge of
the senate budget committee he's really
the one who's prodding the biden white
house to stick to the left to do more to
infuse the economy with money they want
more regulation you have this green new
deal problem happening where biden's
leaving the country this week to go
overseas to talk about how we can give
more money from our economy to regulate
our economy more while they have the
supply chain back up and bernie sanders
is a guy who said that government
breadlines are a good thing
and so when you believe that that's a
good thing then clearly they're going to
argue that what's happening is a sign of
progress this may sound crazy but
talking about good things
inflation is partly a good thing in the
sense that
it's forcing employers to pay employees
more money so people are making more
money they can demand better pay so that
you know that inflates the cost the the
owner has to pass the price on to the
wage gains are being wiped out by
inflation so you're not seeing the
benefit of that i remember to katie's
point how trump closed in the election
he says joe biden and his radical
puppeteers want to turn this country
into venezuela what do we have real
though we have high gas prices we got
high crime we got corruption we have
empty shelves political
prosecutions and then i remember how joe
biden closed his campaign what did he
say he says i'm not going to shut down
the economy i'm going to shut down the
virus well what did he do there's been
more people that died from kobe 19 under
joe biden than under trump and the
economic recovery is sputtering so
if i were joe biden i would say let's
bring the factories back from china
let's stop the reckless spending let's
close the border and joe biden's not
going to do any of that geraldo and
that's why is it 39 approval on the
economy 60 of the country thinks we're
going in the wrong direction and i don't
see how it gets any better after this no
matter how good you talk up the economy
if you're going out shopping if you're
balancing your checkbook or filling up
your gas tank american consumers don't
feel good about it and that's the point
and terry mccullough for one martha is
very worried about it i got this note i
get the uh the notes from terry
mcauliffe he says he's flabbergasted
virginia went big for joe biden and now
i'm tied uh terry mcauliffe writes i'm
tied with a trump-backed culture warrior
who's pushing trump's big lie i thought
folks would be fired up to get out the
vote but at this point it seems like
enthusiasm is at an all-time low rights
terry mcauliffe please send fifteen
dollars
and then yes of course
terry mcauliffe is uh is looking at the
situation and saying you know i thought
this was gonna be easy um this is not
easy uh the education issue i think is
the hot button in virginia that that
glen yonkin rightly you know politically
grabbed onto when he said you know i
don't macaulay i don't think parents
should be you know writing the
curriculums um but the number one thing
is the economy and that that's where
people live right they think it's the
economy stupid again they see absolutely
they see what's going on with the with
the uh supply chain and i i can think
about rahm emanuel saying you know never
let a good crisis go to waste right i
look at these things as leadership
moments
you could go out to the go out to the
ports get the national guard get those
trucks moving get people driving around
say look it's not a permanent solution
but we're gonna do everything we can
start rearranging where these containers
are going you know talk to the company
sit down with them you know they say
they have these listening sessions and
they brought in all the stakeholders
people to judge said and then what
happened
nothing right they do seem distracted
and they talk about things that run past
where people are right that they're
talking about things and people go okay
that's fine you know that's nice and
everything but that's not what's going
on this cultural stuff is running past
the problem but i just want to quickly
make a pitch for my plan to lower the
age of drivers of those trucks from 21
to 18. free up a huge pool 18 19 20
years old you got to be 21 to drive
those big rigs don't i think it's
ridiculous
they don't actually interact with
anybody geraldo but he has to have some
energy to fix the problem and he seems
distracted he does you know a million
things that opening of the clip what did
he say trump in fact he said trump i
think 24 times once for every time he
forgot where he was
uh he's not all there and i don't just
mean cognitively i mean on the job he's
a wounded antelope on the plane and it's
not republicans who are doing the
feeding it's it's the hard left they see
and they know this is a hollowed-out
vessel uh it's collapsing you've got
you're gonna get the bail reform the
high taxes it's time to look past this
wounded antelope and see the vultures
that are circling behind him and above
him because those are the people in
control hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else